sergeant win no thanks man that's not
what why do we even need grand Guard
personnel here matter Myron Institute
has strategic value to the Dukes inner
circle that's all I was told you know
how it works someone there as a response
to violent crime and foreign
interference in our affairs travel
between districts is restricted to those
carrying the appropriate permits let me
know Newark London between Seoul and one
to the trail guard and their enforcement
do only met the exercise of course any
complaints such as the behavior of the
Grand Guard should be addressed to the
nearest Guardsman
more there mantle and enrolled lamp
route I spy a drink oh man dude I had
this Porsche diagram Italy from TV small
makes good money when more bad things
have happened here in the last five
hours of a people know we use much
pretty much anything but meeting of
tailors would G
so let's see what was it Hey
Oh
somebody's now
one night one night
you make sure she stays patient never
leaves out of mine remember there sir
this is it the other night she went
missing and I still them got out
maybe we're not clear on this corporal
in case anyone asks the good doctor
never leaves the grounds unless it's on
official business for the Duke got it I
think I understand sir
don't they accept my transfer we've got
to get over to one of the other
districts
I agree I said it Walter something's
gotta give isn't crash whatever them
uh-huh what sounded like broken cloud
I've never seen blood flies this bad one
there
hello anybody the whole place I don't
have time for that
the store was supposed to be closed
Oh get off me
what are you waiting for
oh mercy you won't get away
are you a patient mine I'm sorry
hey I should know that I'm here to ask
you about something do you call your
face because you were hurt the
afflictions we treat here are more
common than anyone likes to admit not
here for treatment I'm looking for Anton
Silva oh yes he was here for a short
time but she took him away to see Karen
Jin - do you do you hear something what
about the crown killer a patient of
yours the crown killer that name came
from the newspapers I'm afraid I don't
oh yes the murders I was in dunwall
studying diseases found among whaling
crews wait did someone just call me I've
been forgetting things the crown killer
is an interesting case I feel almost
sure I could help was that it's just I
used to do such good work and now my
memory is failing me who is that calling
me excuse me
you